pogchamps 3 is brought to you by gaiuki
as gayaki celebrates 25 years
of regenerative yerba mate they want to
thank you
for being a part of their mission
achievement to steward and restore
over 200 000 acres of rainforest come to
life at gaia key dot com
slash chess that's fine it's it's fine
right there was nothing i could do it
was oh god
keep it going
[Music]
we are about to
practice game with his friend sapnap
it's great to see that
that table is getting his last minute
prep in
with his good friend seth oh maybe
they're ready for an exam nope that's i
think
on top of screen already the right game
against his opponent
rain wilson here we go uh
reigns got a bit of a deceiving 703
there
uh that i think he's literally only ever
played two games and rain starts with
exactly what we thought he was going to
play
okay very good now probably g6
or knight f6 and just to explain in case
you didn't know
um the rating the rating that levy was
talking about
uh rain hasn't been using this chess.com
account
for any other games but the one game
against the world champion magnus
coulson and the last
three games in pogchamps he's stepping
into the
a similar pattern that you showed in the
magnus game
the capture on f7 but turbo is playing
so
fast he didn't see it it's still there
he has bishop f7 this way you always
need to look for checks this bishop is
unguarded and you can move the knight
with a check to then pick up the bishop
so
taboo has got an and again
three moves straight he's vibing
to the music but he's missing out on a
big opportunity
oh and now the other bishop is coming
off
that's probably a bad move whatever
no it's not whatever elbow
what is this on the screen what is this
oh my god oh my god chat you're lagging
out here
guys i'm just dreading that i'm dreading
this
so much this isn't his account
i swear i saw him at rank 1 300
yes like last time he did that's correct
oh when he's played bishop takes b2 we
can't really see it but
we feel it the bishop seems to be
unbeatable
and sabo has no way of saving them not
off to the bestest of starts
that has been made more apparent
yes temple's gonna move his knight so
that he loses at least the rook for the
bishop
it's not that terrible though if he
realizes that by moving the knight he
will at least capture the bishop because
that doors great bishop
is an important piece when you go for
the fianchetto setup that being this
g6 push so at least the queen on a1 in
the corner will be attacking
the other rook uh in the corner too
that could be a dangerous situation i
think rain will spot it
actually for rain it might be best not
to even take like see the eval
the eval actually preferred maybe going
back
because rain's rook is hanging and the
only way to prevent it is by
placing something on f6 or e5 he pushes
pawn to f6
we usually warn our students
not to move the palm but actually it's
working out perfectly because double is
hanging his bishop
no tabbo that's a one mover man
slow down is this making a few moves
with something beautiful like rook g8 or
queen h3 first
i like queen h3 first he pushes d5 to
get the rook to the g
file nice
nice nice queen h38 very nice very nice
yeah i think that first game against
michelle and i kind of gave us the
strange perception of rayne's skills i i
do estimate his ability around
like 1400 if i have to say which puts
him satosh uh
i mean there's a lot of those guys who
could beat each other benji fishy is a
so he's so good you better add ludwik to
the
list too because i think he is watching
our show right now a lot of vegan
number one favorite of the tournament
last i checked he was
i think he was doing a chess piece to
your list it was i mean to be honest it
was
honestly very accurate um he put
i don't know how how he managed to love
that's the beauty of ludwig as a creator
you know there's like how many chess
pieces and he manages to make a tier
list of chess pieces
exciting like i know it's crazy original
the idea
and how can you make content out of
something as
boring as the chess pieces and that's
said by a
chess professional well anna we've made
chess interesting in its chess
you know like at the end of the day we
should also give ourselves a little bit
of credit
it really is chess i mean think of a
game that's not had any improvements for
thousands of years except the pawn
moving diagonally
literally they invented a rule like
because they were bored what's next
so this 2.0 better come out soon because
yeah
we are running out of ideas oh it's uh
it's it's bad i mean maybe the ability
to use
like if you take a piece for the next
move that piece can act like the piece
it just took
i don't know i don't know for maybe only
one turn i don't i'm just saying
fiji will we see checkmate next move
though
new rules or not it's checkmate on the
board with queen to g2
uh well yeah oh god okay in the meantime
that's fine it's it's fine right there
was nothing i could do
it was oh god game two has just started
with
a very classical opening the rui lopez
or spanish opening and double
blitzes out bishop to c5 yeah rookie a
i mean there there there's also d6
there's queen
[Music]
the aggressive way yeah it's not perfect
because probably white can like take and
take a pawn in the center
uh but uh i love it because it opens the
position there's going to be tactics
like take
you know take and if you take on e5 what
ultimately happens is
f2 and e5 tied together via f6 or d4
yeah like for instance even now
like for example queen d6 knight c6
queen g3 is already looking or bishop h3
is looking interesting
just getting all the way over here
again that's a difficult pattern to spot
that you could
in the future place your queen on g3
because
you see the pawn on f2 and you think
that pawn sees you
on g3 you say you don't want to go there
you don't want to vote this gambit
but the bishop on c5 is pinning the f2
pawn and that's why all those patterns
are possible
and bishop a7 was played to his credit
now we get knight c6 double don't hang
your queen
yes i think we have seen enough bottas
gambits today
it would be ideal to move the queen it's
not the same line
as we were describing with the bishop on
a7 the difference is that now when the
queen attacks the c6 knight
that knight will capture the bishop so
it's not just a hanging piece it can
capture the bishop
of tabo and perhaps the most cruel thing
is that if you play queen a4
that's crazy he sees it if knight a7
queen a4
knight c8 the knight will take both
bishops and if knight takes
rook takes the knight now has a getaway
brutal chest is brutal comes down to one
square
yeah what a difference it would have
made if that bishop
was not going to be hanging even in that
position i think it was chaotic because
e5 is a pawn fork and all that stuff but
yes the two knights being on the same
diagonal
this x-ray attack i wonder if after
knight takes a7
which is very likely i think rain will
spot that now the knight is in trouble
on c6 and he
he has to move it with a capture he has
to make a forcing move
to not lose the a4 knight but after
knight takes a7
will we see queen takes a4 and trying to
claim that the knight on a7
has no way back maybe it's much more
likely though he just takes back on a
seven it's like a snap snap it's right
in his face he doesn't have to think
about it
ah well we're about to end uh while
there you are right
you're right and the knight had another
capture funnily enough
rain is getting out of these patterns
because after queen takes a4 the knight
could have captured the other bishop
on the back rank yes so queen takes
would have led to knight c8 now rain
either has to defend his knight
okay very good or jump it around from c5
to d3
oh double sticks on e4
which was a free pawn but it comes with
the price
the price is the e file the pin and the
knight can be
won by a palm push a simple pawn push
yeah he's not
realizing that it's not about the queen
ultimately
it's the night right so
and then yeah i don't have a plan
i don't have a strategy i don't have
anything
oh what do i do here
that's not a bad move bringing the rook
to the semi-open fight attacking the
pawn on e4
what is my thing i need a thing someone
someone come up
with a thing for me
rain has protected d4 pawn and is ready
to develop his bishop
queen g6 is a good idea pinning the g2
pawn and threatening bishop takes h3
yeah actually seriously
with the debate of the oh but queen
queen of three guards the porn range
sharp you know he moves his queen i move
my queen and then i'm gonna get my
bishop out this way
yeah but that idea you could still try
to get that
idea and if you bring the rock to the
attack rookie five is on the board and
the potential rook lift
yeah tabo is saying i don't have a plan
and then just rattling off a couple of
gangster moves look at that
that really is a gangster move and the
rook is heading toward h5
will he guard the pawn now it's hanging
the pawn on d4
or just go all in with rook h5 anything
can happen with this time please don't
go rookie seven taboo
don't go here don't go here ah i'm so
scared
i'm so scared rook c7 and rook d7
hit now plays bishop to h3 oh no
after the queen trade the rook can
eventually be taken on a7
oh my gosh just when he almost
played his way back into the game with
material down
doubles going for stalemate that's
what's going on i was gonna say that's
the final chance the final hope that you
run out of legal moves
but he might i mean but it doesn't even
matter because rain actually wins
regardless
oh his community is spamming the
well-played emote
it was well played i'm a i'm listen i'm
a letterman it really was a good fight
i'm gonna let him know that was that was
a good game and he's gonna come in here
and he's gonna be all
you know oh he killed me and this and
that and
um now confidence is
everything as we've seen time and time
again michelle had that she
she was like hard on herself she was
like i already messed up and she hadn't
she hadn't messed up it does feel like
the psychological side
is getting to the participants too as it
happens oftentimes with chess i always
say
it should not be overlooked that you
probably think you're lost before you
actually are
lost so it's it's something to to bear
in mind
that if you think that you already
messed up
look again because perhaps it's not true
that you have messed up and by thinking
you have messed up you will
indeed show it on the board that now you
are screwed
and after rook f2 there is only
one move and i think doubles just having
the solemn moment he's about to play a
move and he's about to get checkmated
rook f7 is made in one
um
he did the same thing i have faith that
he'll make a move in the next 10 seconds
uh he did the same thing versus logic he
sat there for a while he wallowed
and there you go king h7 on the board
here comes rook f7 from rayne wilson
checkmate on the board queen of eight
would have been stalemate this is
checkmate and what a match this has been
yeah almost come back by trouble rain
you were telling uh taboo right before
we went live you were you felt under
pressure in that second game
he had me on the ropes in that second
game i mean i was a pawn or two up but
um he played so aggressive and he just
kept coming and just
bringing pieces and i was really like
nervous i was
super he was throwing the kitchen sink
at my king side there and
it was nerve-wracking he's got a natural
such a natural aggressive
chest instinct he's the killer
thank you i'm gonna go a step further
anna i you know you you and i spoke
obviously you guys can't hear us during
the commentary this is what i was gonna
say i know i know rain won the match
tubbo
that was the best attacking plan i've
seen in this tournament
so uh you what you need to do is stop
googling openings two minutes before
your game
[Laughter]
i was just clicking the next arrow as
fast as possible trying to memorize as
many as i could
for upcoming matchups rain you're taking
on uh you're taking on maybe the other
kind of big dog in the group and that
and that's logic
have you visualized how that's gonna go
you're gonna assert dominance there be
you know win the group
how are we feeling um well i'm certainly
gonna try and win the group
um but yeah i haven't seen logic's games
um i understand he's pretty good and um
a super solid player and
you know it's this is really
nerve-racking
this whole experience like i was talking
to a friend about it it's like
even when i go on like chess.com and i'm
just like playing a stranger like i get
sometimes i get like that kind of
adrenaline of like oh
screw up um but then you know like tens
of thousands of people are watching you
like they're watching my and then you
make a dumb move and you're like wow
67 000 people watched me do that dumb
move and i could have taken that piece
right there you know
and so it's it really messes with you
but um
i hear logic's great and i'm gonna have
to look at some of his games and
and uh hopefully danny's available to
give me some coaching uh
uh in the next day or two uh get get
honed up
tempo my my son is 16 he loves your
videos man
oh thank you he's a big big fan he's
like oh my god you're gonna play
tubbo oh that's amazing oh that's
awesome
thank i you john a music connection too
because
both of you i think have a nice
collection of instruments double
can you show some of the instruments
behind you thank you very much
it is the still pan or drum sorry this
is this is my one
oh nice i think it's a bit
i bought it purely so i can do the start
of under the sea
[Music]
that is the whole reason i have this
oh my god thank you so much for showing
it and rain i think you have
uh another instrument nearby you yeah
i got my bassoon right there amazing
the bassoon i've got a little guitar
down there
you know yeah it's all right around anna
have you played instruments
i'm trying but i feel like a very much
not talented person
in the company of these gentlemen i've
played a few instruments over my life
and now
you know like a good chess player i play
nothing i just play
chess and that is what i do uh but ford
is your instrument
there you go that is beautiful that is
beautiful
um and uh gentlemen
thank you those were fantastic games uh
we go back to the drawing board you both
have match-ups coming up so we wish you
all the best in those future match-ups
and
uh taboo thanks for staying up late once
again
we'll see you uh we'll see you when we
see you in a couple days
i appreciate it thank you for having me
you guys i'll catch you later
bye
you